non et à propos d'environnement comme
promis notre invité maintenant nicolas
hulot qui veut mettre l'environnement
justement au coeur de la campagne merci
d'être avec nous vous publiez un livre
plateforme pour un pacte écologique ou
vous soumettez dix objectifs et cinq
propositions à tous les candidats et
vous envisagez toujours d'être vous même
candidat d'abord le contenu et le
lancement de ce livre vous étiez très
entouré ce matin arnaud boutet mathieu
dreujou la droite le courtisent une
partie de la gauche le réclame mais pour
mieux se faire entendre le médiatique
nicolas hulot c'est d'abord s'entourer
julien clerc florent pagny luc besson
pascal obispo
le message est simple nicolas hulot
briguera l'elysée
s'il n'est pas écouté j'ai entendu
ségolène royal dire hier que ma
candidature n'était pas utile et bien je
prends acte de ça elles me sont inutiles
à a eu des candidats de la rendent
inutiles son pacte écologique fixe cinq
conditions
création d'un poste de vice premier
ministre chargé du développement durable
instauration d'une taxe carbone qui ne
cesserait d'augmenter des subventions
réservées à l'agriculture de qualité
plus de démocratie participative
enfin une grande politique d'éducation
et de sensibilisation
le scientifique hubert reeves confirme
qu'il ya urgence
si vous ne vous occupez pas de
l'environnement l'environnement s'occupe
de vous et durement et a rapidement tous
les socialistes et dans 50 ans à tout
niveau de la démographie
j que ce soir environnementales tout le
monde on va notre personne
le truc c'est pas de se dire que dans
cinquante six focus et de se dire qu'on
a 50 ans pour changer ça 66% des
français considèrent qu'il est le
meilleur candidat écolo nicolas hulot a
envoyé son projet à tous les candidats
déclarés pour la présidentielle si ces
derniers le refuse l'animateur mettra sa
menace à exécution en se présentant
devant les électeurs